near mansard Astra has been farming
seaweed here for more than 20 years it's
hard work and it always has been but now
his crop has been put to a new use
creating environmentally friendly bio
plastics the seaweed grown here on NASA
Pineda an island close to body could
eventually be turned into biodegradable
packaging the sea itself may hold the
solution to the plastic the plight set a
me studious colleague a little loud in
the Orlando when the plastic like he
follows that Yolanda trusted in Quran at
evangelistic party so that other two
young men in blue can pellucidum in :
the problem is especially pressing here
Indonesia is the second biggest plastic
gluta in the world after China and farms
like this are under pressure there used
to be hundreds on the shores of Nusa
Penida alone but more and more they're
being redeveloped for tourism this is a
small farm it's the last farm on this
island and the tehnology
isn't commercially proven yet the
problem it's up against is huge but
perhaps this is the start of something
here's what that seaweed looks like
turned into biodegradable plastic unlike
normal throwaway sachets this packaging
dissolves in water before we can do this
all by ourselves we are not supermen
right we need to engage like everyone's
from the government sector private
sector or like end customers because
like by doing this together I think we
can really solve the problem because
it's huge problem is everyone problems
earlier this year a British diver swam
headfirst into that problem I was
swimming under at this this swim
probably took me five or ten minutes
really yeah
yeah it's probably the hundreds four
kilograms of it on here on that day
this massive plastic cloud formed off
the same island where seaweed farmers
are growing their crop it was full of
all kinds of waste plastic bags cups
wrappers they don't buy the grade so
this slick will just drift and drift
endlessly through the ocean it's each
wet season from November until April May
time you'll see clouds going past and
we've just seen more and more clouds and
then bigger clouds a bit going faster
each year so it is getting worse every
single year definitely we'd buy weed
nietzermann is toiling towards a more
hopeful future when he live and work
here in the space between the land and
the sea the distinction between them
becomes much smaller making a start on
the problem matters a lot more Tom
Cheshire Sky News in Nusa Penida
Indonesia